[Music]
Wow you're wearing the the Pied Piper
jackets everyone on stage is wearing
wool yeah you're an incredibly hot
auditorium wearing wool and those look
awful they look absolutely terrible much
yeah they're also incredibly hot so it I
smell like Ellis Island
now wait you've maintained because
there's an episode of the show obviously
where these jackets debut and they
become chick magnets you have maintained
that you think you look pretty good in
this Jen reluctantly liked this jacket
and I know that it's not objectively I
know it's an ugly thing but I love it
just so you know it has everything going
for it rats rat
eponymously it what number are we
you'll still note that every letter is a
different color yeah yeah it's truly
it's truly - it's the worst idea ever we
really if you've ever had a fantasy
about being a NASCAR achieved it right
yeah well it's kind of I think well we
all think it was kind of based on our
terrible decision to make jackets for
ourselves in real life we all decided
that it would be a pretty cool thing if
the cast kind of like made jackets for
ourselves they warm around the lot we
call ourselves the rude boys them a lot
on the studio Sony Pictures lot and we
think the writers were like not on our
watch right put this into the show just
to humiliate you yes that's such as
pasta take us down a peg now quality of
ours is like made out of sweatshirt and
this is like silk line like we made
really shitty ones they'd be really nice
ones those are gorgeous though
congratulations to all of you
you